so air travel appears to be back in a
sense as travelers feel comfortable
flying again that's helping airlines
find their feet
unexpectedly it's also led to the return
of a passenger plane model that was
supposed to be on its way out the airbus
a380
the aircraft parking lot in victorville
california where australian carrier
qantas parked its fleet when the
pandemic hit
lockdown travel restrictions almost
bankrupted the global aviation industry
now the world's planes are gradually
taking to the air again including one
model thought retired
the airbus a380s are stored in
victorville and that's for a good reason
it's very very dry it's less humid than
alice springs and we also have a team of
engineers our engineers qantas engineers
based in los angeles so about two hours
drive from victorville in order to carry
out the periodic chests so you don't
just park the airplane and walk away
you've got to do checks every week every
fortnight every month every three months
etcetera
qantas aims to slowly get its a380s back
into service next year
other carriers like singapore airlines
and british airways plan to have theirs
airborne again within the next few days
and weeks
it's a response to a massive surge in
ticket sales
the a380 can carry over 850 passengers
it's the largest passenger plane in the
world
but airbus has discontinued production
due to lack of demand
airlines say it's too expensive and bad
for the environment his days looked
counted
now however the graceful giant looks set
to make an impressive comeback
[Music]
all right let's get more on this from my
colleague chris kober he joins me here
in studio
chris good morning first of all the a380
we talked about this couple years ago
it's supposed to be on its way out right
is it seeing a revival now of some sort
to some degree to some degree uh if we
look at the airlines that are back
flying the plane now it is a a of japan
which is waiting to commence a380
connections to hawaii meanwhile flying
it on domestic
connections emirates has the biggest
a380 fleet in the world now connecting
27 cities worldwide again uh with the
super jumbo uh singapore airlines is
back flying it uh qatar airways wants to
do that soon british airways wants to do
it soon and uh qantas as well okay so
everyone's now flying this thing after a
period of not really flying many planes
at all where's this all coming from why
suddenly are these these planes coming
out of the the dust bin i guess well it
was mentioned in the report i mean video
chats are a thing now well guess what
surprise sitting across from your client
or your customer is still a thing as
well and with business travel bouncing
back back much stronger
than anticipated there is demand there
for for tickets
which is also driven by the fact that
the us
will relax some of its entry rules for
travelers from the european union
next week so this is adding to the spike
in demand and carriers are trying to
cater to that with the biggest
commercially
pla plane made ever okay but in some
ways this seems like overkill even
british airways is running a flight
between london and frankfurt with the
380. that that seems very unnecessary so
why uh it is necessary in the sense that
the plane was grounded for such a long
time during much of the uh pandemic and
now getting back to flying it again
pilots need to train they need to get
the feel for it again because flying
this sort of pain differs from having
just you know these jets that serve a
medium medium hall connections so they
are flying this on shorter routes trying
to get in as many takeoffs and landings
as possible
okay so everyone's pulling out the old
380s um a380s how long is this going to
last they're supposed to be not very
economical in the long run right are
they scrapping them which is still true
it won't be viable in the long run we
have to understand that passengers love
flying on the plane they really like the
plane what they also like though is
going directly from whichever wherever
this journey starts to their destination
also mid-size airports what they don't
like is first going through these big
hubs where the a380 is stationed so it
is it is it doesn't really have a future
added to that the fact that it is a four
engine plane so it's very costly to the
carriers to the environment and as a
matter of fact its days are counted
airbus will deliver the last models of
the a380 to emirates this month and
here's another sign that
times are changing emirates is actually
uh has begun stripping its first ever
a380 for parts to be turned into
furniture into memorabilia and once they
start picking you apart your time is up
so before it's really received its last
it's picking apart one of its first
exactly all right that makes sense the
economics of the aviation industry
always a mystery chris kober from dw
business thank you very much
you